so you're in love with her absolutely
I'm really happy because I get Demi we
have something really special just well
that was in August and things have
changed since then there's trouble in
paradise for not one but two bachelor in
paradise couple I don't really know what
just happened well let's break it down
after calling it quits on the beach
to giving things another shot I'm finale
night will you be my girlfriend I feel
like I've made a really big mistake
letting someone go that genuinely cared
about me tisha Adams and John Paul Jones
have officially called it quits tisha
confirmed their breakup on Instagram
saying we were living on opposite coasts
and working insane schedules that made
it impossible to see each other and
build a life with each other et talked
to the Parana gasps they shared how they
were managing living far from one
another right now we are doing
long-distance so the iPhone is our best
friend a lot of FaceTime FaceTime every
day and I think I think we've sort of
agreed to try to see each other twice a
month you know every two to three weeks
JPJ moved to Los Angeles earlier this
month seemingly to be closer to tisha
who lives in Orange County I'm taking
things you know day by day more sad news
a source tells et that another bachelor
in paradise couple is on the rocks
I just always not been a fan of
committing I like to do whatever I want
to do and I like to have fun after
making history for being bachelor
nation's first same-sex couple who also
got engaged on the show
agony of course
a source tells ET that demi burnett and
christian haggerty's relationships are
same quote extremely rocky post
engagement
it's a bachelor road news faster than
the engagement that's what ever people
like actually like take the time to be
slow about Demi and Christian haven't
posted a photo of each other on social
media for over a month their last
pictures together these on September
19th just two days after the VIP finale
breakup rumors intensified this week
when Demi shared a sexy bikini shot to
Instagram and Christian sister Caitlin
commented not desperate at all the pair
seemed very much in love while speaking
with et in August they said they'd be
down for a televised wedding in Mexico
next year but noted they were happy to
just be together for a while they'd be
normal for a bit and date and have fun
and then the wedding will come it's
insane how we're so different but it
just works so well you know I'm so blunt
and bold and all kinds of things and
she's so gentle and understanding and so
sweet and soft and it's just like a
perfect balance
[Music]